[inaudible].
Oh well,
welcome everyone.
I'm assuming that applause was not for
me.
My name is Bill Flanagan and I'm the
dean of law here at Queen's University
and I'm pleased to welcome all of you
here today for the inaugural liberty
lecture,
generously sponsored by Greg Kids that
ski law 80 a long time and very generous
supporter of the law school and Greg is
here today and I just want to perhaps
the join me in thanking Greg for
sponsoring
[inaudible].
The Liberty Lecture is intended to
explore the meaning of liberty in our
contemporary society,
the subject of rich interest to
philosophers,
political scientists,
and legal scholars.
Just to name a few.
And today's liberty lecture is moderated
by Professor Bruce Party to my right of
the Faculty of Law and experts in a
variety of areas including environmental
law,
environmental law and governance,
ecosystem management,
climate change,
water law,
and university governance.
Our guest today is Dr. Jordan Peterson,
a professor of psychology at the
University of Toronto and a clinical
psychologist.
He as many publications include his
recently published book 12 rules for
life,
an antidote to chaos and his research
spans a number of topics including the
psychology of religion and the modern
understanding of creativity and
personality.
I know that today's lecture has
generated a great deal of interest as is
evident from the packed hall here today.
It's also generated a certain amount of
heat.
The proposed topic,
the rising tide of compelled speech in
Canada is for many a controversial one
and I know that many of you in the
audience will hold widely divergent
views.
I fully support your opportunity to be
heard and should you wish challenge the
speakers to defend their positions.
I know that today's speakers likewise
share this conviction and we'll welcome
your comments and questions as might be
appropriate for a lecture series named
after liberty.
I believe it is also important for me to
affirm at outset that the core values of
the Faculty of law end of Queens
University include academic freedom and
respectful dialogue among those with
differing views.
This includes providing our speakers
with the opportunity to be heard and
providing all of you with the
opportunity to respond in a respectful
environment,
free from any harassment or any attempts
to shut down the conversation.
So it is in this spirit of free and
respectful academic exchange that I'm
pleased to launch her this new lecture
series.
Welcome again and welcome to our guests
and I look forward to our discussion.
Thank you.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thank you bill.
Welcome and thank you for coming.
I would like to underline what bill
said,
which is that this event would not have
happened without the initiative in
support of Greg Kids.
Esky.
So Greg,
thank you very much
[inaudible]
as well.
Before we start,
I would like to thank some people from
the Faculty of Law,
Diane Butler at him,
Blake Galippo and Christina Julian for
their help in putting this together.
I would also like to acknowledge the
support,
help and generous assistance of several
people around the university.
Uh,
Lisa plater and event services,
David Patterson and the,
uh,
campus security office.
Uh,
you have been professional,
helpful,
straightforward and I thank you very
much for making this possible.
I would also like to return to the
flannigans observation about the
importance of this moment and to
acknowledge the role that both Dean
Flanigan and principal wolf have played
in enhancing the reputation of this
university in terms of its commitment to
academic freedom and academic debate.
They have
reflected an unflinching commitment to
those ideas.
As principal of Wolf said on his blog,
informed respectful debate is central to
academia.
And Gentlemen,
I salute your academic statesmanship.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible] so we're
going to proceed as follows.
A the first thing I would like to say is
that in the hole behind you afterwards,
there will be some of Jordan's books on
sale.
12.
Um,
what,
what's the title again?
12 rules for like 12,
12 rules for like wanting to get the 12
what it was,
right?
It's not,
that's not 12 steps.
It's 12 rules.
Right?
Um,
we are going to proceed as follows.
Jordan and I are going to have a
conversation for half an hour,
maybe 40 minutes and then we are going
to throw the floor open to questions.
We'll describe what kinds of questions
that you should ask.
Wait,
I don't want to get to that stage,
but our topic is the rising tide of
compelled speech in Canada.
I am going to take just a couple of
minutes to give us some context and set
it up and then I'll ask Jordan to tell
us what he thinks.
You may have seen the CBC production of
the tutors.
The story of King Henry the eighth
in one episode,
the king has condemned Thomas Moore to
death
for refusing to say that the king is the
head of the Church of England
more is it his cell awaiting execution?
A friend comes to him to plead with him
to say what it is the king wants to
hear.
Morris says he cannot do that for he
does not believe it to be true
in exasperations.
The friends says
you don't have to believe it.
You just have to say it
when your brain makes that kind of
calculation.
You know you are under the thumb of a
tyrant
and Thomas Moore lost his head.
The tide of compelled speech in Canada
is rising.
The Law Society of Ontario has
introduced a new policy that requires
each lawyer to develop a statement of
Principles which endorses and
acknowledges an obligation to promote
certain values.
The Ontario Human Rights Commission says
that under the Human Rights Code,
failing to address somebody by their
preferred Pronoun will constitute
discrimination for which you may be
investigated and prosecuted.
The Elementary Teachers,
Federation of Ontario has introduced new
curriculum
to require teachers to teach elementary
students about white privilege
and the Federal Summer Jay Grants
Program requires applicants to attest to
the values,
but the government believes it.
Okay.
They don't have to believe it.
[inaudible]
that's pure narcissism at work,
by the way,
[inaudible]
it due to hijack hijacking event like
this that other people put time and
effort into and to use the civility of
the crowd and the civility of the
organizers as an excuse to blatantly
yellow.
You're ill informed opinions is no way
to conduct a civil dialogue.
It's absolutely appalling.
The people who do that,
she'd be embarrassed.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I would also say that as students and as
faculty members,
you shouldn't put up with it.
There's no way that you should allow
people who are doing this to hijack your
educational opportunities and to bend
and twist the functions,
the structures of the university.
It's not a good thing.
Not In any way at all.
He would say that was a very disgraceful
display fundamentally.
So let's,
let's stick with it.
Why,
why do you think people are afraid of
free speech?
Well,
you know,
people develop an ideological view of
the world because they don't want to
think through things in real detail and
they're aided and embedded in that
endeavor by their pathological
professors who are feeding them.
Uh,
what would I say over simplified?
An oversimplified radical view of the
world in my estimation,
is fundamentally based in,
in resentment.
Not that there's no reason for,
say,
a left wing view of the world and we can
get to that later.
It's easy virtue.
You know,
you can stand up in front of 900 people
with your plot card and your and your
screeching and you can,
you can declaim to the entire audience,
your fundamental moral superiority.
You can tell everyone at once that
they're all beneath you and you're
standing for the right thing and
absolutely none of that is earned.
You know,
like what the hell?
What the hell was that?
There's no seriously man,
there's just,
it's just complete misbehavior.
It's embarrassing.
And the fact that people,
the people who do that don't have enough
sense to go hide their head in shame
just tells you how badly socialized they
are and how terribly educated they are.
And the thing is,
the thing that's so awful is that there
are professors and educators who promote
that.
They say,
well,
that's how you change the world.
It's like it is how you change the
world,
but it's certainly not how you make it
better.
You make it worse.
Clearly,
you know,
there is no comfort in that and,
and there's nothing about it this
impressive.
It's no,
it's no better in some sense than a two
year old having a tantrum on the floor.
It's a,
it shows as far as I'm concerned,
it approximate the same level of
psychosocial development.
So when the fact that that this is
happening continually universities is,
it truly makes me embarrassed to be
associated with the university.
And now I say that with great
displeasure because,
you know,
I'd been working for great universities
for a very long time and the university
has an absolutely remarkable
institution.
You know,
it's survived for a thousand years.
And,
and to see it,
to see it brought down by,
by people whose behavior would be out of
place at a four year old's birthday
party is,
is something something bizible to
behold.
So,
so what about the actions of government
now,
because it is government after all,
that is the source of this compelled
speech as law,
as well as other ways in which they seek
to restrict speech.
But the compelled speech is the most
egregious form of violation.
Well,
tell us about that.
I've been trying,
I've been trying to sort this out
because you know,
if you're a clinician,
I would say one of the problems you
always have when you're dealing with
behavior that's gone astray is to
understand at what level of analysis you
should address it.
You know,
is it a theological problem?
Is it a philosophical problem?
Is it a psychological problem?
Is it social,
is it economic?
These are very complicated questions.
Is it a trivial issue?
Is it an issue of rights?
Is it,
is it something else?
The people who put in the bill see 16
for example,
and its associated legislation make the
claim that it's,
it's a legislative move that's
facilitated by nothing but compassion
and desire to expand the domain of,
of,
of let's say,
of of rights and freedoms.
And you know,
there's nothing wrong in principle with
expanding the domain of rights and
freedoms,
except of course for every right and,
and for every freedom there's an
attendant responsibility and obligation.
So you have to keep that in mind.
When I looked at bill [inaudible] 16 and
the legislation that surrounded it,
especially that was written by the
Ontario Human Rights Commission,
the policies that surrounded it and also
the policies that gave rise to the
social justice tribunals named social
justice tribunals.
Appallingly enough that that that gave
rise to those tribunals in Ontario.
The things I read just made my hair
stand on end.
You know the social justice tribunals
have the right to place themselves
outside of legal [inaudible],
outside of jurors prudential precedents.
It's like,
what the hell is that?
That's really what you're going to make
the case.
The only way I think that you could
justify doing that is it if you torture
yourself into the ideological
proposition that English common law is
somehow an oppressive branch of the
patriarchy.
And because of that you have every right
and even obligation to place yourself
outside of its structure of precedent.
But we don't want to.
Police are so outside of the structure
of precedent of English common law.
I can tell you that it's,
it's one of the supreme achievements of
the human race.
It's,
it's produced societies that are as free
and as productive as any societies have
ever been anywhere on the planet and
certainly are now and t to dare to state
that you would place yourself outside of
that precedent.
That's the sort of thing that made my
hair stand on end.
And there were other elements of the
policies that were equally
reprehensible,
not least,
their complete incoherence of
formulation.
You know,
I couldn't understand some of it,
like I don't understand,
for example,
with regards to the gender,
uh,
propositions,
how it can be that you can be anywhere
on the gender spectrum,
which by the way,
it's not a spectrum technically,
and it actually matters which words you
use.
If you're writing law,
you can be anywhere or nowhere on that
spectrum.
Like,
I don't know what that means.
And I don't believe that the people who
wrote it,
no,
what it means either.
And you don't write things that you
don't understand into the damn law.
You don't do that because the law
unfolds in society and it tangles people
up as it unfolds.
And it's no joke when that happens.
So you'll be very,
very careful when you're writing law and
you certainly don't want to write law to
push forward your ideological
commitments,
especially in the face of precedent
because precedent is what keeps law from
degenerating into audiology essentially.
So and so.
Well,
and so,
you know,
tap to answer your question,
more,
more fundamentally,
I don't believe that this argument has
ever been about the rights of
transgender people.
I think that it's an attempt by the
radical left ideologues to push their
ideological agenda forward using,
using,
they're using attempts to manipulate the
linguistic domain.
And I'm not willing to seat the loot
linguistic domain because I don't think
there are any more,
anything more important than the words
that you use.
And then when the government says we,
you should start using these words,
you should start thinking hard about
your damn government because your words
are no different than your thoughts and
your thoughts.
Orient Yourself,
your thoughts orient you in the world.
And if someone who's going to tell you
what it is that you have to think,
then they're going to disorient you and
the world.
And I wouldn't recommend that because
there's lots of terrible things that can
happen to you.
And if you're disoriented,
you're going to run into a very large
number of them.
So that's how it looks to me.
So,
but,
but the
ideological context of this,
it seems like something has changed.
Yes.
Because if you think back decades
earlier,
liberals were,
the champions are free speech.
I guess it was the conservatives at a
certain moment in time.
Who are the sensors,
you know,
they,
they sought to curb a blasphemy and
obscenity,
sedition and so on.
And the,
and the Liberals said,
no,
free speech is the way we want to go.
And yet today that has flipped.
Uh,
if you,
if you look back to what left leaning
officials and authorities and,
and,
and figures said,
lemme just give you one quote.
This is Samuel Gompers who is the
founder of the American Federation of
Labor in 1886 he said this,
he said,
the freedom of speech has been granted
to the people in order that they may say
the things
which,
sorry.
Misquoted,
that have not been granted to the
people.
In order that they may say the things
which please and which are based upon
excepted thought,
but the right to say the things which
displease the right to say the things
which may convey the new and yet
unexpected thoughts.
The right to say things even though they
do a wrong.
Now that is not a sentiment now carried
on by the left and today.
What has happened?
Well again,
I see that it's a consequence of
continual adjective agitation by I would
say a minority of of the left,
the radical left in particular,
and those are people who aren't Marxist
Slash Neo Marxist in their fundamental
ideological orientation and have joined
that in an unholy union with the worst
of French postmodernism and they push it
ideological certainty.
And the thing that,
the thing that's really distressing
about that is that if you know anything
about the history of oppressed people,
let's say much as I hate to engage in
that particular form of dialogue under
the current conditions,
it's pretty obvious that it's freedom of
speech is freedom.
That's particularly important for people
who don't have anything else,
right?
It's,
if you're supporting freedom of speech,
you're not supporting the status quo.
I mean,
just think about,
let's,
let's use the logic of the radical
leftists and assume that society is a
tyrannical hierarchy and the people at
the top have the upper hand in
everything,
including access to communication.
These people are not your friends.
Hmm.
Can you say
mark my words,
the sounds of the barbarians pounding
out the gate,
right?
Yeah.
That's all.
I'll tell you again,
that use of in Kuwait,
what would you call it in Kuwait
sensation is the best formulation of
their argument.
And there's not much difference between
knocking on the doors and knocking on
you.
So keep that in mind.
It's not amusing.
There's nothing to it,
there's nothing for it.
The thing that's also quite appalling is
that there's no evidence whatsoever that
the people who are conducting these
protests,
no.
What it is that they're protesting
against.
You know,
I was in,
all right.
I was in the midst of a discussion and
attempting to make the case that it's
freedom of speech.
That's it is what people who have
nothing still have.
Right.
So if you look at the tyrannical
structure of our society,
let's say the people at the top have
access to means of communication.
Everyone knows that it's the people at
the bottom who have the right to say
what they think,
however badly they say it,
that enables them to get a toe hold into
the system and to,
and to make their suffering known.
That's what freedom of speech is for.
And so like what's the protest against
that?
And I'll tell you,
you know the rowdy called Neo Marxists
types.
They speak the language of power and
that's what you're speaking right now.
And if you want to live in a world where
everyone speaks the language of power,
then just let them do what they're doing
and see what happens.
I wouldn't recommend it.
It's not a pretty rote.
And you're all in a position,
you're on a situation in your life now
where you have to make decisions about
this sorts of things.
Like is this the sort of institution
that you want this to be?
What are the,
uh,
one of the
arguments against what you said about
the pronouns.
Yup.
Was that?
Well,
after all,
all you're being asked to do is to say
something that is reasonable.
It's not unreasonable to address
somebody by the pronouns that they
prefer.
And yet,
if you think of any kind of speech which
is prescribed,
imagine a statute that said people shall
use the words hello and please and thank
you in their conversations.
That statute is untenable.
Yes.
Because it now requires people to use
certain words in their conversations,
even if those words are reasonable
themselves.
So that is not the question and it was
not your case.
You are making that using a pronoun was
unreasonable in itself,
though I have that correct.
Well,
yeah.
First of all,
there's a couple of things I'd like to
say about that.
No,
I looked up the process by which the
Ontario government formulated it's
legislation with regards to the pronouns
and the consultation process that used
and the consultation process was deeply
flawed.
They contacted activists and say,
let's activists of the Trans Community.
Okay,
well there's a couple of things I'd like
to say about that.
The first is there is no trans
community,
right?
Trans people are as diverse as any other
group of people.
And to the idea that somehow because of
one of their attributes,
they constitute a homogenous group is,
uh,
well,
you think that that would be a false
with dip,
the people who are concerned about
treating groups of people adequately
would be loath to,
to put forward.
But even more importantly,
there's absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that the activist types are
actually representatives of any of the
communities that they hypothetically
activate on behalf of.
It's like they're not elected,
they're not appointed,
they don't pull,
they do this.
They say,
look,
here's a group.
It's a minority group and it's
oppressed.
I'm a member of that group and therefore
I stand for the group.
It's like,
actually no,
you don't.
You don't stand for your group.
You may be standing for yourself.
You know,
I don't stand for men and I don't have
to stand for white men.
I'm not,
I'm not entitled to speak on their
behalf.
And so the idea that it's the trans
community that wanted this sis I
completely unsustainable idea.
It's certainly unproven.
I've had like 40 letters from trans
people since I started to engage in this
call.
It
is chaotic battle.
The only one of them was mildly critical
of what I was doing.
All the other ones,
there aren't that many trans people,
you know.
So to get 40 letters is actually quite a
few.
And I'm not saying that this is a
scientific Paul,
but it's at least as scientific as the
process by which the Ontario government
generated it's legislation.
Hmm.
And I'm not generating legislation.
And what these people said to a person
was,
I didn't ask to be the newest whipping
boy for the radical postmodernists.
All it's done is made my life more
difficult.
You know,
that basic letter would say,
well,
I'm transitioning from one gender to the
other and it's very difficult and I'm
not sure that it's the right thing to
do.
And this has made the process
spectacularly more difficult on all
fronts.
It's like,
and these people don't speak for me.
And just because they say they do that
doesn't mean they do.
And so the other thing that we seem to
have swallowed as a society is this
crazy notion that,
well,
first of all that we should be portioned
up into our different minority groups,
which I think is a return to tribalism,
an unbelievably dangerous,
I can't really think of anything more
dangerous than that.
And then we've swallowed the idea that
if you identify yourself as a member of
a minority group and then you bring
forward a grievance,
you have to be treated as if you're a
valid representative of that group.
It's like,
Whoa,
why in the world would we do that?
It's guilt,
I suppose.
Maybe that's part of it or I think it's
mostly guilt.
You don't want to stand up and say,
well,
you know who died and made you king so
to speak.
You know?
Can we,
can we stay on that logic for a moment?
The,
the idea.
So this,
this compelled speech material seems to
insist upon treating people not as
individuals,
but as members of groups to either blame
them or to favor them as a member of a
group.
Like we take that logic and extend it.
You know that the group identity thing
becomes intersectionality where you're
not just blogging to one group,
but you're also have these
characteristics.
Spin that out for us.
What,
what?
What is the logic of that?
Where does it lead us to?
Well,
okay,
so the first thing I would say to
everyone in the room is,
I don't think,
and this is why I decided to do with
what I did right from the beginning,
you know,
is that I don't want to play the group
identity game.
I don't want to construe the world in
those terms and I'm not going to use
terminology that would require me to
formulate my thoughts manner.
I think it's a terrible catastrophe to
divide us all up into our tribal
entities.
I don't see anything positive about that
at all,
so I just don't want to go there.
And then second,
I would say,
and maybe this is even more relevant,
you may or may not have heard about
intersectionality.
Intersectionality is a new development
on the radical left.
And I think it's actually,
if I wasn't so in tandem to Quan
seriousness in these matters,
I would be constantly laughing about
intersectionality.
And the reason for that is that it's the
radical left has discovered its own
Achilles heel.
So look,
what's the problem with dividing us up
into groups?
Well there's many.
And,
and the descent into tribalism is not
least among them,
but the next is that,
well it doesn't,
it turns out that we don't fit into one
group.
Any of us,
we fit into multiple groups and it's not
obvious at all.
Which of those groups should take,
should be of paramount importance.
You know,
there's a ratio group and an ethnic
ethnic group and there's groups of
intelligence and there's groups of
temperament,
new scripts of attractiveness,
and there's groups of wealth and you can
multiply them really indefinitely.
And I do mean indefinitely because you
can categorize a finite number of
entities,
a virtually infinite number of ways.
And so the intersection lists discovered
this.
They said,
well,
there's,
let's say there's Latinos and there's,
and there's Asians.
It's like,
okay,
well wait a minute.
There's male and female Latinos.
And there's male and female Asians,
so so do we treat,
is the division into two enough or do we
need a division into for a while?
And then,
well then there's socioeconomic class of
male and female,
Asians and male and female Latinos and,
and you can keep fractionating the
groups and and technically without,
and,
and you actually see this happening in
real time,
so to speak,
as the,
as the acronym for the LGBT activists
continues to expand really without end.
And see what's at the bottom of
intersectionality.
And this,
I suspect,
will be discovered eventually by the
radical leftists if they get that far,
is that you have to fractionate the
groups right down to the individual.
And that's what Western culture
discussed in articulated,
discovered in articulated over the last
5,000 years.
It's like,
oh,
right.
The group isn't the paramount division.
It's the individual because unless you
treat each person like an individual,
you're not taking all the intersections
into account.
And so it's extraordinarily,
it's extraordinarily comedic,
but it also isn't as if it's treating
everyone as they're an individual,
as if they're an individual,
is an instant solution that will bring
us to utopia.
You know,
it's,
it's like Winston Churchill said that
democracy,
right?
It's,
it's essentially the least terrible
approach we have.
And Life isn't the sort of problem that
is amenable to an instantaneous utopian
solution.
But our best bet is to meet each other
with the desire for peace and
productivity on this,
on the stage that enables individual
interaction because then we meet soul,
the soul,
so to speak.
And we also meet in a domain that we
bear responsibility for as individuals.
And that's also extremely important,
right?
You should be responsible for what you
say.
You should have to suffer the
consequences of what you say,
not least so that you learn.
And so the individual is paramount as
far as I'm concerned.
I think that's the fundamental principle
of Western civilization know it's not
only the west that has come across that
discovery,
but I think we've done the best job so
far of articulating it.
And so we don't want to lose that
because the alternative isn't a
multicultural utopia.
The alternative is a descent into tribal
barbarism and,
and there are people who would be just
as happy if that happened.
But I would suggest that it's not a
destiny that in a weak person would,
would,
would long for.
Yeah.
Do you feel like taking a few questions,
do you feel like taking some questions
from the students?
Sure.
All right,
so we're going to have questions and
we'd like you to participate in this
conversation now.
Please do ask a question.
We welcome you up to say what you'd
like.
If there is a preamble to the question
that's fairly shorts then so be it.
But please do ask a question.
We're not actually anybody speeches and
we do primarily want to hear,
but Jordan has to say.
So feel free to line up at the two
microphones.
We'll take one at a time.
Go ahead sir.
Uh,
so first of all,
thank you so much for being here.
I really enjoyed it.
Um,
[inaudible]
and a second,
I'm,
this ties into my question I had just
last week.
My free speech coalition at Bishop's
University was officially ratified and I
would love to invite you to be our first
guest speaker if that's at all possible.
Um,
thank you.
and my,
my question pertains to this,
um,
for Dr. Peterson,
what would you consider the most under
discussed or overlooked ideas and topics
that you think should be discussed in
the club?
Because I know we're looking for
controversial ideas that we think are
maybe not as discussed as much as they
should be.
Well,
that's a difficult question.
I would say that
it isn't obvious to me that on
university campuses at the present time
or in the education system in general,
we've done a good job of taking stock of
the advantages and disadvantages of our
current sociopolitical systems now.
And I think there's enough data so that
we could start having intelligent
conversation.
So one thing I would recommend to you
all if you're interested is a book I
just finished reading.
It's called the great leveler,
the great leveler by Walter Shy Dale.
And it's a discussion of inequality and
it's a very intelligent book.
So one of,
so inequality,
as you may or may not know,
is rife throughout human societies.
Right?
And that's the case in the present day.
And it's been the case historically,
but it's also the case in animal
societies by every measure.
So inequality is the rule of life,
let's say.
And that doesn't mean it's not an
ethical catastrophe.
I'm not saying that,
I'm just saying that the fact of
inequality cannot be laid at the feet of
the west or of capitalism or,
or really have any human construction
for that matter.
One of the things Shydel did was to
investigate empirically the relationship
between inequality and the pole of
government.
So because let's say if you,
if you surveyed a very large number of
states,
you could determine whether this,
the governments were left wing or right
wing,
and then you could,
you could do a compilation of inequality
coefficients and you could find out if
left wing governments had any,
any ability to ameliorate inequality.
Just as an empirical question.
And the answer that Shydel generated was
no,
there's no difference whatsoever in the
inequality coefficiency left and right
wing states.
And what that points to is a much more
fundamental problem.
And shydel in his book also points out
that the only known historical forces
that limit inequality or that produce
equality are war revolution and
pestilence.
It's doesn't look like it's easily under
under human control.
And so,
you know,
the Marxists talked about inequality and
the fact that capital tends to
accumulate in the hands of fewer and
fewer people,
which is sort of true except that the
people at the top tend to rotate lot
more quickly than that.
Then the communists and the Marxists
separate presumed,
but it doesn't look like that's a
consequence of capitalism.
It looks like it's a much deeper process
and capitalism at least,
well it's shoveling money and resources
up to the top also does lift the bottom
very,
very quickly.
You know,
and this is something we need to have a
serious discussion about it at the
university.
So like one,
cause we shouldn't be doing this,
we should be partying in the streets.
And here's one reason why do you know
that the level of absolute poverty in
the world fell by 50% between the year
2000 and the year 2012 do you know that
was three years faster than the most
optimistic UN projection considered?
It was the fastest decline in absolute
poverty that the world has ever seen.
And like that's a big deal.
You know about,
there's hundreds of thousands of people
that week right now that are being
connected to the power grid and almost
everybody has access to high speed
computation.
And the,
the,
the struggling economies in Africa have
for the last four years being the
fastest growing economies in the world
know there's almost no absolute
privation left.
There aren't people starving except for
political reasons.
We're at a point where obesity is the
worst problem than starvation,
you know,
and,
and now I also think that a lot of that
was purchased out the cost of the,
of the dreams and hopes of the working
class in the west.
You know,
I think what we did some stamps for
about a 30 year period with sacrificed
the aspirations of the Western working
class to alleviate poverty,
get India and China and in Southeast
Asia.
And it looks like that might've been a
really good deal,
although it was a little bit hard on the
working class people and that has to be
taken into account,
but we're not having discussions of is
sort universities.
It's like we're stuck in 1980 or maybe
in 1960 we haven't updated our bottles
to take into account the new and often
extraordinarily positive realities and
we're tearing ourselves apart in the
west with this identity politics,
idiocy at the same time that things are
getting better and better,
faster and faster than they ever have by
a huge margin in the history of mankind.
So it's like,
it's time to wake up and throw off the
impression of the Cold War and to look
around and see what's what's available
in front of us and what we could upon
that would be much better than Oh yes.
Yeah.
So
told that,
uh,
there are developments outside.
I'm sorry for the noise.
The uh,
we'll,
we'll they're doing the best they can.
Uh,
yes ma'am.
So was there a fetus and you've said
that Eric had was,
or one of your most priorities is the
pursuit of truth.
Um,
could you just clarify what you mean
when you're presented with a situation
where you have to worry,
you're being asked to refer to someone
to their preferred pronouns and is it,
is it a true thing you see,
is it their truth is your truth
be the issue
requested the individual to be addressed
to a certain matter?
It's the compulsion of that by law.
So at least issues get conflated
constantly.
Look,
I've dealt with all sorts of people in
my life,
a much broader range of people than most
people ever encounter in the course of
their entire lives.
And I'm perfectly capable of deciding
how to treat someone on a one to one
basis.
But when the demand for,
for terminology becomes part of the
legal system,
I don't care what the rationale is,
it's not happening as far as I'm
concerned.
And people say,
well,
we're pushing it forward because of
compassion.
And maybe you could start just being
such a mean professor.
It's like,
why should I believe that?
You know what the hell you're doing with
your compelling laws.
You're willing to,
you're willing to move past illegal wine
in the sand that's been drawn for let's
say 700 years.
You do not write compelled speech into
the legislation all but we're doing it
with the best of intense.
Yeah,
no,
you're not.
So these issues have to be separate.
Look,
if this was
about transgender rights,
it would have disappeared in September
of 2016 it's not about transgender
rights and everyone knows it.
So this is not about transgender rights.
What these,
what these people are doing outside.
It's about something far deeper than
that.
But can we ask the question this way?
Can we say,
don't it doesn't everybody have the
rights,
the liberty to decide how to present
themselves?
You know how to be who they want to be,
what to wear.
You know what,
what gender to call themselves.
And the answer is yes.
Everybody has the liberty to do that.
What everybody else has liberty too.
And the liberty to do that doesn't mean
they have the right to compel other
people to agree with it.
In other words,
liberty is not the right to demand that
the world validate the choices that
you've made.
You have your choices,
you have the freedom to make the choices
and everybody else has the freedom to
make their choices too and to approve or
disapprove.
But they call you this or like all your
that.
In other words,
liberty is a two way street and
everybody has it.
And the fact that you've made choices,
it doesn't mean everybody else doesn't
have the same ability to make the same
choices.
Yeah.
Back,
back.
Mike,
Please go ahead.
Hi,
that was loud.
I just want to thank you for being here.
I'm really big fan and um,
I have a bad habit of making or,
uh,
getting in arguments with a lot of
radical leftists and I'm the most common
argument they present to me,
I generally is bills you 16 only covers
the Ontario human rights code.
So those are protected areas under the
Ontario Human Rights Code,
uh,
such as,
universities,
uh,
elementary schools,
et cetera.
I was just wondering how you would
combat this argument?
Seeing is their argument is generally,
um,
they're only dealing with vulnerable
groups such as young students and um,
he's still good about
it doesn't matter.
They say,
well it's,
it's restricted in scope.
Yeah.
It's not restricted enough.
Look,
I mean,
here's a couple of facts.
Okay.
So
when I first made my video is about bill
sees 16,
one of the things that I suggested was
that the act of making the video itself
could well have been illegal.
And of course,
people immediately accused me of fear
mongering done perhaps with reasons.
It's not always easy to understand the
full intent of the new piece of
legislation surrounding policies.
But I can tell you one thing.
When the lawyers at the University of
Toronto read through the new legislation
and the surrounding policies,
they also decided that what I was doing
might've been transgressing the law.
And that's why they wrote me two letters
telling me to stop.
Okay.
So that's fact number one.
Fact
number two two words.
Lindsay Shepherd.
Okay,
so
let's say for the argument that I'm a
paranoid megalomaniac and that I'm a
bigot and all of the other things that
people have decided that I might be
okay.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
in my paranoid Megalomania,
I never envisioned a situation where a
teaching assistant,
a 22 year old teaching assistant at a
major Canadian university would be hold
in front of a quasi myo is inquisition
and have to record it because she dared
to show five minutes of a video from a
mainstream news program run by public
television funded by the government of
Ontario.
So paranoid as I was,
let's say,
it isn't obvious that I was paranoid
enough.
So,
and I don't see that.
I don't see how either of those examples
can be disputed.
You know,
it wasn't like the University of Toronto
wrote me two letters without thinking
about it.
They went and consulted their high
powered lawyers and the lawyers reviewed
the policies and the legislation and
they thought,
oh,
Dr. Peterson,
he might be contravening that
legislation.
It's like,
it was a weird paradoxical gift to me
that they sent out those two letters
telling me to stop because it was
instant proof that what I was doing was,
um,
I wouldn't say right because God only
knows about that.
But at least it,
my interpretation of the bill and its
intent was correct.
So can we just make this observation
that,
that response to Jordan's critique of
[inaudible] 16,
the one that went,
oh he's overreacting.
Nobody's going to be punished or sent to
jail for this is silly in this stance.
Remember,
every single legal rule there is,
is a legal rule only because it is
backed with the mom,
monopolistic violence of the state.
They're re
[inaudible].
There's no such thing as a rural without
punishment.
So if,
if for example,
there's a no parking sign,
what the practice science says,
oh by the way,
please don't park here.
But there are no tickets.
Well people are going to park cause
that's not really a rule.
So if you have a rule in the human
rights code,
and if you breach it,
if that's discrimination,
well then true that the first thing that
happens to you is not going to be thrown
in jail.
But there's a process,
a series of steps,
right?
The first one might be a mediation or an
investigation,
and then there might be a fine.
And then if you don't pay the fine,
then your wages might be garnished or
you might be ordered to fix it.
But believe me,
if you refuse and refuse and refuse and
refuse,
that order will become a court order.
And then if you don't obey the court
order,
you'll be in contempt of court.
And then that will lead to arrest and a
presentment.
So every single rule in the human rights
code
is effectively enforced with the most
severe violence the state has,
even though it's not actually practiced
most of the time because most people
obey
when we,
we also don't want to underestimate,
I don't know how many of you have had
the pleasure of being dragged before a
board that investigates your behavior,
but I would tell you that even if you
don't end up paying a fine or in jail,
there's nothing particularly pleasant
about the process itself.
It's enough.
You know,
you wonder why people don't speak up and
I can tell you one of the reasons that
they don't speak up is because merely
being dragged in front of a board of
inquiry,
innocent or guilty is enough to pretty
much do you in for a whole year.
Like if you're a sensible person and
you're concerned with propriety and you
want to maintain the stability of your
life and your reputation is important to
you,
perhaps because of the stip,
the stability of your family depends on
it to be investigated for such things as
a punishment.
All of it's all,
it's no,
it's no pleasant business and many of
you will stuff I would,
I would equate being investigated by a
non punitive port,
let's say with these punishments that
Bruce described quite hard on the
distance.
I would equate that to having a,
a fairly serious disease in terms of
its,
in terms of it's psychological and
physical impact.
I would also say no,
I won't say it.
Let's go with an express right place.
Thank you.
First of all,
they can vote
as embarrassing as what's happening out
there is for peace university.
I think what it does want to hate your
show,
how we're doing here is and how we can,
those people are so thank you.
First of all,
in terms of my question,
most of your belief that it's extremely
important.
Everything that we're doing,
um,
to speak our mind speaking really that's
why we're here.
But um,
in terms of practicality,
there's a lot of things that get in the
way of her license students.
We have our
prospective.
So,
um,
in terms of practicality,
what are kind of maybe your tips and
your perspective on the steps that
students can take to kind of speak their
mind while not sacrificing your future
prospects?
Well,
I can tell you a couple of things that
are very practical.
Don't write in your essay is what you
think the professor wants to hear.
There's absolutely no excuse whatsoever
for doing that.
Now,
first of all,
most professors,
even those who have descended into a
state of ideological possession,
say most
of them still have enough character to
braid and essay that's well written
properly.
So you're actually taking less of a risk
than you would think by stating what you
have to stay.
But if you start practicing when you
were in university glue mistakes,
you're rather low pandering to the
audience,
let's say and say,
what do you think will get you buy?
You're going to train yourself to do
that.
And what that means is you're going to
train yourself in the false
certification of your character and your
character is the only thing you have to
guide you through life.
No people dream of riches.
And they dream of luxury and all of
that.
But that's a thin defense against the
harsh realities of world.
You have your character.
And so what you do when you go to
university is you learn to see what you
think is clearly as you can and to take
the slings and arrows that come along
with that.
Not In an arrogant manner,
right?
Because like,
what the hell do you know?
You know,
so you've got plenty to learn,
but you want to formulate your thoughts
carefully.
You want to write what you think.
Well,
why?
Because when you're writing,
you're thinking,
you're laying out the arguments that
you're going to use to structure your
existence in the world throughout your
entire life.
And if you start to twist and bend those
for expedient reasons,
you're going to warp your soul.
And I mean,
I could talk about that
neurophysiologically if you want to,
you know,
you become what you practice,
you automate what you practice.
So if you automate expedient speech for
the sake of short term gain,
then that's what you're going to
produce.
You're going to produce expedient speech
for short term gain.
Well,
God help you if you do that,
like there is nothing that you will
possibly do in your entire life that
will serve you better than to get
control of your voice in university.
I remember seeing you do that by
reading,
right?
You read great people.
You do that by writing what you think.
You stay true to yourself while you
write what you think,
and you take the risks and you gain the
benefits that go along with that.
You learn to stand up and speak and to
listen carefully,
and that makes you a negotiator of
unparalleled power.
And if you're a negotiator of
unparalleled power,
there's nothing in the world that won't
open itself up to you.
So that's what you're doing in
university.
And if you find professors who,
who reject that,
and there's fewer of them than you might
think,
then it's your sacred obligation to
stand up for yourself against that,
because it's going to happen to you
throughout your whole life.
And you might as well start practicing
how to do it right now.
So that's how it looks to me.
Yeah.
There's an old saying that I,
I right.
[inaudible]
I write in order to know what I think.
And you'll note how compelled speech
interferes in that process.
Yes.
So the idea that you have to write what
your wants is the form of compelled
speech.
It's like it.
I really do believe that this is a
fundamental issue as a therapist,
say when I'm trying to help someone set
their life straight,
I do my best not to compel their speech.
And the reason for that is quite clear.
It's like you have your destiny with all
its attended triumphs and sufferings and
it's on your shoulders.
I don't want to tell you how to think.
I don't want to tell you how to think
because I do not know how you should
think.
You have to figure that out for yourself
and then you have to bear the
responsibility for that.
And you,
you were a terribly arrogant fool.
If you dare to tell someone else how it
is that they should conduct themselves
through life.
Now.
I mean,
having said that,
while obviously I say,
well,
you should tell the truth,
or at least you shouldn't lie,
but that's not a dictate of,
of,
of action,
so to speak.
It's a dictate of process.
It's like,
well,
you can't,
you shouldn't interfere with the
mechanism that allows you to solve all
the problems that you will face in your
life.
And you come to university maybe to
prepare for,
uh,
for a,
for a profession,
no,
and to set yourself up economically,
but to set yourself economic up
economically,
properly.
I don't care what your profession is
going to be.
There is no one who is more powerful
than someone who can communicate.
It doesn't matter what the field,
it doesn't matter if you're a plumber or
a politician.
If you can formulate your thoughts
clearly.
If you can conduct yourself honorably in
your action and your speech,
if you're articulate and careful,
then the world opens itself up to you.
You have an unlimited horizon of
possibility.
So thank you very much.
Yup.
[inaudible].
Oh,
thank you both for coming with,
firstly,
I'd like to thank everyone in the room
was not devolved into the hysteria we
see outside.
They would prefer that we lost our
sanity and that our society with
fracture into the nonsense we see.
So by sitting here,
being as patient as you are,
this is how we keep our academy.
This is how we keep our society.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
my question is a simple one.
Uh,
we see more and more of this new
language I call of leftism,
intersectionality,
equity,
diversity,
inclusion,
and we see people from all political and
philosophical stripes adopting this new
vernacular.
Is this in any way dignifying that as a
position,
is this dignifying the philosophical
bases of these words?
Do people recognize that when they use
these links,
these words that they were making that
somehow a truth that we all ought to
accept?
I don't,
should we or should we not?
I don't think people,
you recognize that.
Again,
you know,
I'd like reiterate,
the reason I made those videos to begin
with was because I don't,
I was unwilling to cede the linguistic
territory as soon as you think it's
already happening to some degree.
So imagine that we just defined the
sociopolitical landscape in terms of
identity politics,
which is happening very rapidly.
In fact,
we're compelled to do so.
Right?
So,
um,
well then,
then what happens is you get activity on
the identity politics front on the left
and on the right the left says,
well,
the oppressed shall rise and take their
rightful place.
And the right says,
yeah,
over my dead body,
and probably yours too.
So as soon as we played the identity
politics game,
that's where we're at.
And we start playing it by accepting the
terminology.
You know,
already I find myself stumbling when I
use the word sex instead of gender.
And that's not good.
Like I have to consciously overcome a
resistance to use the word sex instead
of gender because you know,
I'm actually quite an agreeable person
and it actually pains me to,
to go against the crowd.
Let's say,
you know,
I'm not temperamentally suited for it
precisely,
strangely enough.
And so I feel the compulsion to use this
kind of language welling up inside of me
just to be,
to be nice,
I suppose,
you know,
but I know where identity politics
leads.
It leads to the ghoulag.
It leads to the concentration camps.
It leads to blood in the streets.
We don't need that here.
We're doing pretty well.
So we could leave it.
[inaudible]
hi,
Professor Peterson.
Uh,
I studied history for the duration of my
degree and I think it's just a
sickeningly ironic that the people who,
uh,
are using their free speech,
one to take away your free speech and
furthermore,
that they can't see the irony of the
situation of how tyrannical there being
a,
my question is,
however,
I've noticed from a lot of what you've
talked about and I've been watching you
since your rise in 2060,
2016,
um,
and I know that you're a Christian and I
don't want to divulge into that,
but I notice a lot of sort of North
American Protestant work ethic in,
in,
uh,
in your lessons.
Like,
you know,
uh,
self redemption and to be your own
person.
Like we've been talking about that last
like hour and a half I suppose.
And um,
in a ever rising tide where people are,
or rather in the western world where
it's becoming increasingly rather
decreasingly Christian and specifically
it's,
yeah.
Decreasingly religious in this
specifically decreasingly Christian,
how can you,
what do you think is the best suggestion
in order to be able to uphold those such
important values that have been across
the world,
uh,
from the American cultural influences
since the end of the Second World War?
I apologize for the long question.
No,
no,
it's fine.
The no,
people have asked me repeatedly my
religious views,
and I've
answered them in a variety of different
ways,
but they say,
do you believe in God,
let's say?
And my response to that always is,
well,
I don't know what you mean when you ask
me that question.
So I don't know how to answer it.
I don't know what you mean by belief,
but I can tell you something that I
believe and I would say this is a way of
speaking symbolically.
I do believe so.
I was thinking the other day and we
could go,
I was thinking about this I this little
fantasy that entered my mind.
I was thinking about Saint Joseph's
oratorial in Montreal and Saint Joseph's
oratory.
It was a very large religious building.
It's one of the biggest cathedral like
structures in the world and it's set on
the hill and mount royal and it's set up
where it can catch the sun,
you know?
So it's an image of the heavenly city on
the hill,
right?
It's an image of the structures that we
strive to create.
That's what it is in independent of its
specifically Christian or religious
function.
That's what it stands for symbolically.
Okay.
So it's the city on the hill.
It's,
it's what we're striving towards when we
walk up hill in life.
Okay.
Now,
the way that the oratory was structured,
there's hundreds of steps leading to it
up front.
And in the early part of the 20th
century,
a lot of people who had physical
disabilities came there and they
struggled up the step on their crutches
and many of them left their crutches in
the oratorial.
You can see hundreds of them if you go
there.
It's quite an interesting site.
And I was thinking about that and I was
thinking about what that meant and this
is what it means.
It means that you know,
everyone has their disabilities,
let's say,
and I know that some people are far more
terribly effected than other people.
I'm perfectly aware of that.
But the question is what do you do about
that?
And what you do is you,
you set yourself up on your damn
crutches and you struggle up the bloody
hill.
That's what you do.
And you struggle up the hill towards the
Kingdom of God.
That's what you do because the
alternative is to descend into the
abyss.
That's the alternative.
And then so to say,
well,
do you believe it's like I believe that
you should struggle uphill towards the
city of God on your crutches.
That's what you should do.
That's the opposite of the descent into
the abyss.
And so that's,
that's at the foundation of our
civilization.
That idea.
Well,
argue with it.
If you will,
see if you can figure out why that's not
an acceptable idea.
Maybe you should help someone's struggle
up the hill.
Perhaps you should,
you know,
you can lend a hand to someone or you
don't want to take the burden away from
them entirely because there's something
noble about struggling up the Damn Hill,
right?
There's something that's adventure.
That's the call to proper being.
It's like,
well we don't need to forget this.
No,
we don't need to forget it.
The universities have been there since
time in memorial to try to push that
idea forward through the generations and
everyone needs to know that idea.
That's what gives you life,
not happiness.
Forget about that.
If it comes while,
great,
except it dignity,
nobility,
character,
truth,
responsibility,
beauty.
Those are the things to aim for honor to
and say.
[inaudible] thank you very much and I
hope when all this is done,
I hope you take a nice long,
big vacation cause I think you really
deserve it.
Hello.
Okay.
Peterson first,
thank you for coming and I'm so I'm
trying to ease my parents grew up in the
cultural revolution of China,
so I took particular attention when you
mentioned the multiple occasions
comparing what's happening in the West
right now,
two miles,
China and I,
I agree and it's pretty obvious the
connection between their radiology,
the identity politics and the oppression
versus oppressed viewpoints.
But my question is mostly about how
they're promoting the political agenda.
I mean,
I see that the political agenda,
the philosophy behind the political
gender are very similar,
but at the same time I see a shocking
similarity in the way that they're
promoting that political agenda.
Specifically backing back in the culture
revolution,
anyone who dare to say anything that
it's not fully for the movement was
classified as Ntu revolutionary.
Just as now who anyone who dare to say
anything that goes remotely,
not fully aligning with whatever they
want to promote is classified as hate
speech.
Although it has nothing to do with hate
hating anybody.
So since the same thing is happening
here and a mouse,
China,
what would you say?
Well,
what?
What do you think is the connection
between the philosophy and veer idiotic
s over simplifying and tyrannical way of
him,
of trying to promoting it?
Well,
the first thing,
the first thing we should make clear is
that there is such a thing as hate
speech,
right?
Like let's not be naive about this and
you can use words to inflame and words
can be very dangerous tools.
People use them and hateful matters all
the time.
That's not the issue.
That's obvious.
The issue is whether or not you should
regulate out and even more importantly
whether the state should regulate it.
And the reason that's an issue is
because who's going to define it?
I'll tell you who's going to define hate
speech.
It's the people who are doing that that
are going to define hate speech and
right now they're are defining you
sitting in here as hate speech.
I mean that's exactly what's going on
while we sit here.
It's like who would be interested in
defining the parameters of hate speech?
Here's the answer.
The people that you would least want to
have adopt that responsibility and and
hate speech.
It's like,
let's say I was interviewed a while back
and the journalist asked me,
well,
why should your right to a fan trump
someone's right to be secure?
It's like,
okay,
well let's say I'm talking to one person
and you might say,
well,
I don't have the right to offend them.
It's like,
all right,
what if I'm talking to 10 people?
Do I have the right to offend one of
those people when I speak to the board,
if it's a thousand people,
what you're saying,
you can't,
you can't have a conversation about
something serious without offense.
Like if I'm thinking about something
serious,
like I often myself,
you know,
I know it's seriously mean that I really
mean that.
So like if I'm laying out a set of
hypotheses,
for example,
about a complex social,
a social problem,
I might lay out 20 hypothesis and maybe
two of them.
I think,
God,
I hope that's not true,
but like maybe it is true.
You know,
sometimes you discover things as a
social scientist that you wish weren't
true and those are usually the things
that you've discovered that are actually
true,
right?
Because they violate your assumptions.
So you can't even think if you're not
willing to offend yourself.
That's what thinking does.
If you're ever talking about something
wouldn't be serious if it didn't have
the possibility of frightening and
offending people.
That's kind of how the,
that's Kinda like the definition of
seriousness.
It's like,
well,
we can only talk about things that no
one ever gets upset about.
It's like,
well,
okay,
then it's like you're trapped in an
elevator for,
for the rest of infinity listening to
nothing but music.
You're,
that's an,
that's a kind of hell man.
If you're going to think,
and also if you're going to speak,
you're going to,
you're going to offend people.
You're going to go after their deepest
presuppositions and end your own as
well.
You're going to shatter them at times.
It's going to be brutal.
Absolutely brutal.
And you all know that because every
single one of you has had a serious
conversation with someone that you love
and the probability that that was an
easy conversation and that either of you
escaped without offense and terror is
zero.
If you haven't had a conversation like
that,
well,
well
you're not human,
right?
I mean,
right.
Cause everyone has conversations like
that all the time,
except when they run from them,
which is most of the time and no bloody
wonder,
you know,
real conversations or there's nothing
worse than a real conversation except
the war that you have if you don't have
the conversation.
That's basically how it goes.
I just want to underline,
I just want to underline Jordan's first
point,
which is really that it's a very
dangerous thing.
Any legal rule that relies on some kind
of reasonableness because reasonableness
lives in the eyes of the beholder.
I mean,
those out there think that you guys are
uttering hate speech.
They think that you guys should be the
one who are arrested and just imagine if
they were the ones who had the reins of
government power.
Just all very well.
Thank you.
Both hate speech is a reasonable idea,
but as soon as you give up the control
about what that means,
you're liable to run into real trouble.
Yep.
A little monster.
Whoa.
Mr. Peterson.
My name is Zachary Milligan.
Uh,
first off,
I'd just like to start by actually thank
you for all the hardship and troubles
even dirt for standing up for our rights
and being a part of this debate.
Um,
I come from a dairy farm and math need
rural res conservatively.
And my question is in the face of when
we have a social situation,
so divisive,
when you genuinely believe what you're
doing is the right thing.
In this particular instance,
since you have experience with it,
what would you say?
Is there a more effective,
I don't want to say an easy way to reach
out for them.
What do you think's the best way to try
and talk some sense into those folks
outside and the one on one setting?
So the first thing is is I don't
necessarily the date,
I don't necessarily think that what I'm
doing is the right thing because you
know,
you have to be careful when you make a
claim like that.
But I can tell you one thing,
I'm not going to let anyone stand in the
way of me trying to figure out what the
right thing is.
That's the thing.
[inaudible]
and then I would say we're doing exactly
what we should be doing right now in
this discussion.
It's just exactly right,
right?
I mean,
admittedly we have to talk over the
noise,
but that's really not that big a
catastrophe and everybody's in here is
comporting themselves in a reasonable
manner.
And we're trying to struggle our way
through the topics and we're,
we're asking questions and we're,
we're trying to have a genuine dialogue
about them.
And that's what we've got.
We've got,
we've got three things.
We've got negotiation,
we've got slavery,
and we've got tyranny.
And those are your choices.
And so this is negotiation,
right?
That's public discourse.
And the reason that freedom of speech
thought is obviously important.
Everyone can understand that.
You might say,
well,
you don't need to speak freely because
you can think who's going to get inside
your head.
But the problem with that is that that's
not it.
You can't think very well because there
you are and your little world,
you know,
with all your biases and your ignorance,
you're wrong about so many things and
you're going to learn it really
painfully.
And,
and then maybe you can trot out some of
the things you think erroneously and
ignorantly and other people will give
you a tap on the side of the head
instead of running you over with a
freight train,
right?
They'll give you a little tap on the
side of the head and maybe you'll walk
away a little smarter.
And that's why freedom of speech is so
important is because a lot of thinking,
especially about things that are beyond
you for whatever reason,
have to take place publicly as we
stumble around towards an adequate
formulation of the problems that beset
us.
So I would say,
well in this book I wrote,
I have a rule.
It's,
I think it's rule eight which is tell
the truth or at least don't lie.
I would say,
well,
that's another reasonable,
reasonable way to start approaching the
situation is it's not so easy to tell
the truth because like,
what do you know?
You know,
you can't come out and say,
well,
here's the truth,
but I know what one thing you can do,
which is when you know that what you're
saying is a lie by your own standards,
you can not say it and you can have a
consultation with yourself and you can
try to learn to say those things that
make you strong.
Instead of saying those things that make
you weak and you,
you contribute to the health of the
public dialogue in an incalculable
manner that way.
And this is another issue that pertains
to the dignity and importance of the
individual.
How you conduct yourself in your life is
way more important than you think.
And,
and I,
I mean,
I think that that's a daunting idea
because,
you know,
let's say you're nihilistic and life is
meaningless.
It's,
well,
what's the payoff for that?
I think while there's no payoff,
it's like,
well,
yeah,
there is,
you have no responsibility.
That's a pretty decent pay off.
I mean,
you have to pay the price of
meaninglessness,
but it doesn't matter what you do.
Well,
we'll flip that over and said,
no,
sorry,
you're wrong.
Your life is meaningful.
It's way more meaningful than you think,
but you have to bear responsibility for
your thoughts and your actions.
It's like you'll,
there'll be plenty of meaning and not
well that if you understand that
property,
that will,
that will cleave you to the depths of
your soul and maybe you learn to speak
carefully and to act carefully and that
will have a beneficial effect on
everyone around you if far more.
You're far more powerful in the place
you stand in the place you sit and stand
than you think.
And I think everyone has an intimation
of that.
And if you don't think that's true,
then try treating people around you as
if it's not true.
Tried treating people that you know in
your life as if they don't matter and
just see what kind of response you get.
People are not going to be happy with
you,
not in any sense whatsoever.
You'll,
you'll ruin all your relationships.
You have to treat people as if they
matter.
And maybe you have to treat them as if
they matter because maybe they do.
And that goes for you too.
And so if you matter,
then you should act like you matter.
And that's a very,
that's a very daunting proposition,
that's for sure.
Okay.
As a foot,
go ahead.
As a
[inaudible],
it's just a footnote to that.
Let's just observe this in legal terms.
There are only two categories of
actions,
voluntary and involuntary.
Don't let anybody tell you otherwise,
either you're choosing,
you're on your own and handling the
consequences or the government is
telling you what to do.
Those are the only two possibilities.
Thank you,
sir.
At the back of my head.
Oh Duh.
Hello,
Dr. Peterson.
I would like to recall the part in your
conversation in which you mentioned how
the radical left switched from the 1960s
and seventies to being back when they
were a pro free speech and their recent,
um,
opposition to it.
I know,
I know that you often mentioned their
obsession with power,
at least among them.
Um,
yes.
Uh,
at least among their more marxists
types.
I was one no undoing.
If perhaps they think that now that now
is the opportunity where they can
consolidate their power and if they do
so successfully that it will become the
mortality of our civilization for the
next thousand years.
Like Christianity was when Rome adopted
it.
Is that from what you've seen,
would you say that that's about it,
that that's close to the way there
that's close to their strategy?
Well,
it's hard to exactly understand the
strategy of an ideology,
you know,
because all the people who were outside
were,
were united in some sense under the
umbrella of an idea.
And on an idea is a living thing.
I mean it's,
it's embedded in living tissue and it's
distributed in the fragmentary manner
across the mob,
let's say.
And each person in the mob always only
only possess is a fragment of the
ideology because the full neo Marxist,
let's say the full neo Marxist
postmodernist doctrine is quite complex.
And,
and,
but when you get them all up together,
then it acts under the dictate of the
ideology.
And the question then is,
well,
what does the ideology want?
And I would say,
well,
it wants what it's formulators says it
wants.
And D Derrida,
for example,
who's head trickster of the
postmodernists regarded the western
society as fellow go centric,
right?
And North that meant was male dominant,
male dominated.
That's the fellow tell us part.
And then logo centric.
While that refers to the word logos,
which means it's the root word of logic,
but there's also the,
it's also the,
the person of Christ,
essentially the logos.
And so the purpose of the postmodern
critique was to demolish that wealth.
Fair enough.
My sense with people is,
especially if they're,
if they've written things down and
thought them through that they're
actually aiming what they say
they're aiming for.
Well,
if you,
if you buy the idea that the west is a
male dominated tyranny,
essentially a patriarchal tyranny,
and that your moral duty is to tear it
down,
well then that's what you're doing.
And then you might say,
well,
what's going to,
what is going to be erected on its
ashes?
Well,
that's where things get complicated.
You know,
the first question might be,
are the people who wish to tear it down
builders,
or are they just destroyers?
And my strong sentiment is that they're
primarily destroyers.
Okay.
Now you might say,
well,
why do people wish to destroy?
Well,
it's because they're hurt by life and
they're resentful.
Okay.
And resentful.
People become vengeful and vengeful.
People become dangerous.
And there's no shortage of motivation to
make things worse.
Okay?
No,
the school shooters make things worse.
People make things worse.
Now,
you know,
maybe lurking in the rhetoric is this
appeal to an egalitarian utopia.
But we've tried you galitary Utopia's
already we sacrificed 100 million people
to he galitary and utopias and we have
yet to produce one.
And so my sense is the corpses stacked
up high enough to constitute proof.
So
it's destruction mostly that motivates
it as far as I can tell masquerading as
compassion.
Nice.
[inaudible]
thank you for that question.
Next place.
Dr. Peterson was the party.
Thank you both for being here today.
Um,
I'm a political scientist and what I've
studied is totalitarian regimes.
I'm sorry,
I'm gonna move this a little bit.
Just feel weird.
Totalitarian regimes.
I've studied,
I've tried to look at the Iranian
revolution and the Islamic Republican,
Iran,
and I've argued how the Shia Islam that
is teached in Islamic public is very
close to a totalitarian regime.
But now I live in a country where my
ideas are considered controversial.
If you believe in God,
if you believe in family,
if you believe in having responsibility
and traditional values,
I feel ostracized by the community here.
I came from UC University of Calgary
over there.
I didn't feel this way.
There was more welcoming.
Here I feel marginalized and I do feel
alone.
And when I see this,
it disgusts me that here they can do
this.
But I couldn't go to their events and do
anything.
I'd have to shut up,
there'd be a disciplinary committee for
me.
But for them they can break windows to
God knows how old this building is.
And it's okay for them to do that.
So my question to you is now being sheer
experiencing this,
I'm starting to second guess that maybe
the totalitarian Islamic regime that I
was so,
you know,
talking about I'm critical of back in
Iran isn't so bad when I have a choice
between having to be here and you press
and be there and least have my ideas be
okay with blue regime.
So my argument is if this free speech
and the arguments you guys are making
here,
it doesn't work,
would that not be the next step for
people to go towards totalitarianism?
If dialogue fails and isn't force of
arms the only thing left?
How can people compromise when they
don't want to talk,
when they want to yell?
Thank you.
I think you make it very good point.
I don't think we should fool ourselves.
This is about force and it is a,
it's almost a dare to suggest that that
certain elements are not allowed to
enforce their view of the world and that
speaking contrary to it,
isn't that a front to those values and
they won't shut you down.
I mean that,
that,
that is what is at stake.
We,
we,
we are,
we are no longer really in a situation
where this will all be resolved through
sort of gentle,
reasonable civil dialogue that,
that happens on the side.
But it's not real anymore.
It's not really where the fight is
happening.
This is a,
an imposition of the force of the state
and it is skewed.
It is skewed a certain way and we are
getting to the point where a certain
kind of language occur,
certain kind of dialogue is,
is approved and all right and a certain
kind of is not.
And that is the campaign that is going
on that this is all part of.
And I have to say that,
that your presence here and,
and your endorsement of this kind of
event is the kind of thing that has the
major pushback to that trend,
but the trend is continuing.
And is it very dangerous one.
And uh,
this is,
uh,
a difficult moment in the life of this
country.
Would you,
would you say
Jordan Peele?
So,
so some,
some comments about,
about your career,
let's say.
Okay.
So you're a young mountain and you've
got lots of years ahead of you.
So you know you want to prepare for the
war and not for the battle.
Right.
Okay.
Cause there's going to be many battles
for you personally and perhaps
politically and all of that.
And so you want to make yourself as
articulate and educated as you can and
you want to have patients.
I would say that there's no cause for
despair.
You know,
I believe that the,
the,
the people who are attempting to
radicalize our society and to transform
it into a battleground of identity
politics are in a distinct minority.
And I think that,
I think that there's no reason to assume
that we can't push the devil back into
the,
into the bottle,
so to speak,
to push the genie back into the bottle.
And so don't despair.
Now from a personal perspective,
it's like we've got lots of things to
learn and you've got lots of things to
say and to write and you're going to
find now and then that you were imposed
upon in a manner that you don't
tolerable.
Right.
You think,
I can't live like this,
right?
It's going to distress you when,
well then,
then you've come across your moral
conundrum,
right?
It's specific to you and then you have
to,
that's when you have to grow up and
think strategically.
It's like you decide are you willing to
live under those conditions?
If you're not,
then you develop a strategy.
It's like,
okay,
I'm going to,
I'm going to fight this.
I'm going to fight it carefully,
intelligently,
thoughtfully on multiple fronts and I'm
not going to back down like you don't
make that decision lightly.
You know most things you should let blow
by you because there's not that much of
you and there's lots of things,
but now and then you'll find a stumbling
block that you can't get over it because
it hurts you.
It damages your soul.
That's the right way to think about it.
Well then that's the time for you to put
your education to use.
No,
and you'll be able to do that.
I mean,
you don't want to underestimate the
utility of of deep,
forthright speech.
I don't believe that anything can stand
in its way.
You have the courage of your
convictions,
but don't give way to despair.
Like this battle is by no means over.
Well no I know meets and it isn't even
obvious that the bad guys are winning so
to speak.
You know,
I mean here we are.
Yes,
we're having this talk.
The university came out forthrightly in
favor of free speech.
Hooray for that
[inaudible]
no one and so far all the questions
today have been thoughtful and
intelligent.
You seem like informed people.
It's like don't underestimate your
strength.
And so,
and mcmaster just published a set of
guidelines governing this sort of
behavior so that will no longer be
acceptable to disrupt perfectly
reasonable proceedings on university
campuses.
And so that,
so the discussions like this can
continue properly.
I mean there's definitely a place for
give and take and for informed
opposition,
let's say.
But there's a difference between
informed opposition and child childish
grand standing.
And I think people know the difference
between that.
So don't,
don't be desperate about it.
Why not pick your battles?
Courage goes a long way,
right?
Because other people see it and there's
that,
there is I think a silent majority out
there that is silent and is scared.
But if they see courage from somebody,
they responded to it.
Well,
I think you described lawyers in a way
that appealed to me once.
He said,
I think,
I know that's rare,
but
you said lawyers,
I think these are the words you said.
Lawyers are
difficult and emotionally stable.
And it was the combination of those two
things,
the willingness to be difficult but not
to be emotional about it.
So don't,
don't,
where'd your emotions to the fight?
Take a step back,
engage in it.
Say what you think.
Be Courageous,
but don't get wrapped up in it.
Don't be emotional about it.
But you know,
Rick Chain your strength for the long
haul.
Yup.
Well,
and you know,
one of the things I've learned
strategically,
and this is really worth thinking about
too,
is that when you're engaged in a public
dispute like this,
it's not obvious when things are going
your way.
You know,
you think,
well,
this protest is not such a good thing.
It's like,
I wouldn't be so sure about that.
You know what's happened to me in the
last 18 months is that virtually every
time that I been attacked and some of
the attacks had been quite,
well I wouldn't say brutal because we
haven't got to that thank God,
but they've certainly been um,
they've taken me aback.
You know,
it's not,
it's not a straight forward thing to be
in a hall with.
And this happened at mcmaster with a
hundred people yelling at you and Larry
near horns and all of that.
But that wasn't a bad thing as it turned
out because it was filmed and it was put
on Youtube and it was terrible for the
people who protested,
you know,
it wasn't good.
And so you got to detach yourself to,
you know,
if,
if you say what you think and you're
careful about it,
it's going to have some short term
effects and it's going to have some
medium term effects exit.
It's going to have some long term
effects.
And one of the things that you need to
do,
I would say,
and this is an element of courage,
is you have to have faith that the
medium to longterm consequences of you
saying what you have to say as clearly
as possible.
It's going to be positive and you have
to act on that supposition.
You don't know,
right?
You can't know that that's the
existential leap of faith is you.
You can't know,
but you act anyway.
And my experience has been that you
don't want to,
you don't want to make judgment too
quickly because it's not always clear
when things are going your way.
So when you know,
you might stand up into class and say
something that people react negatively
to eat and you might get pilloried for
that by some people,
but you never know who you're touching
in the crowd and you don't know how
that's going to unfold across time.
Now you,
that might be a defining moment in
someone else's life to watch you stand
up and say what you have to say.
So don't underestimate the power of
truth and courage really.
So
thank you.
[inaudible]
honestly,
they should be thankful.
And how civil and how peaceful you guys
are.
They should be thankful.
They shouldn't be angry.
I regret to say we probably have time
for probably
just a couple of more questions.
So let's go to the back.
Hi.
Um,
so my question is directed at Dr.
Peterson.
Um,
I've been watching your lectures online
for a while and um,
you talk a lot,
come a little closer to the mic.
You speak a lot about that's better as
you speak a lot about character arc
types and a narrative and the importance
of the young Ian idea of the
personal narrative.
Um,
I
am having trouble formulating this into
a question,
but I guess with the idea of archetypes
in mind,
um,
are you familiar with,
uh,
Ben,
we Mandel broads idea of fractal
patterns?
Um,
and if so,
what do you think and if,
is there a connection there maybe to be
found?
Well,
there seems to be a metaphorical
connection in that the,
the great is,
is reproduced in the small,
and that's certainly an idea that
permeates,
let's say religious and theological
speculation.
You know,
there's an idea that here's an idea that
it's like the idea of the genie,
which is the same root word as genius.
You know,
the genie is something of unimaginable
power that's constrained in a very small
space.
And that's kind of what a person is
like.
You know,
we have this affinity,
we have this connection to the infinite,
we have this connection to the divine
but work,
but it's constrained within within our
frames,
right?
And we have to act out that the divine
narrative in the confines of our own
life.
And so there is this overarching
reality,
which is something like the fo the
forthright confrontation with the
catastrophe of life,
right?
And,
but that has to be made personal,
you know,
so that,
that's one of the things I would say
deepest ideas is that the archetipal has
to be be made personally in your own
life.
And so you take the generic pattern and
you personalize it,
and then the infinite and the finite
meat.
And that's the perfect combination.
And there's something about that that's,
well unalterably profiled I would say.
And,
and,
and as true as anything can be,
and I think people know this at the very
deep level because you do know when
you're struggling to go to sleep at
night and your conscience is bothering
you and you think through the things
that you did in the day,
in the week,
you'll take solace in the things that
you did that were noble and true and
you,
and you can,
you can breathe a sigh of relief that
you're not completely corrupt and lost
and then you can sleep.
It's like everyone knows this.
Well,
we need to know it consciously,
right?
And that's part of the process of the
archetipal personal and that that's part
of what the religious process is
supposed to be about,
is to outline the,
the archetipal pattern and then to say,
look,
you have to meditate on this.
And you have to figure out how to make
it true in the confines of your own
life.
And that gives,
see the reason that works,
I think is because there's no doubt that
your life is tragic and there's no doubt
that you have a bilevel and element and
that you'll be touched by betrayal and
all those terrible things.
But there's a nobility about youtue.
And that nobility might be sufficient to
transcend your limitations.
And I would say that your life is a
struggle to determine if that might be
the case.
And that's the act of faith.
But I also do believe I was asked today
by South African journalist if I'm the
ultimate pessimist are the ultimate
optimist.
And No,
and I would say in some ways I am the
ultimate pessimist.
I know I think as much as I can tolerate
how terrible life can be,
but I do believe that the human spirit
can overcome that catastrophe and can
rise out of it.
And I think the universities are that
that idea expressed in stone and
tradition and it's a great idea.
Everyone needs the idea,
especially people who are young,
you know,
your life is it know that your life is
going to be difficult.
It's like no one can say,
well,
it's going to be easy.
But you might say,
well,
do you want it to be easy?
What's in it for you?
If it's easy,
well,
no,
you want it to be difficult and
worthwhile and you want to be the sort
of person that can manage that.
And that's what you should be.
That's what you should be encouraged to
be at university.
And,
and that's what the universities are
for.
So,
well,
that's the archetipal and the person who
I would say.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
we'll have to be our last question.
Go ahead,
sir.
In recent time,
uh,
I would probably identify the most
recent us election as the turning point
for this.
And that's,
I've seen that as an American citizen,
this is my first time living in Canada.
Um,
I've noticed that public discourse has
taken to elevate fascism as the ultimate
evil,
and maybe rightfully so.
You know,
there were many horrific things commit
by fascist states in the 20th century,
and you see people,
you know,
like facebook cover photos,
like bash the fast,
you see,
let stickers on laptops.
This machine kills fascists.
It is,
you know,
there's this big backlash against
fascism and the horrors that it caused,
but in spite of that,
you don't see the same reaction to the
horrors and the genocide that were
caused by socialist and Communist states
in the 20th century.
Do not.
You see people who virtue signal
endlessly about how horrible the
Holocaust was,
about how awful these things were.
And then just hand away the famine,
genocide of the Ukraine,
the great leap forward.
They think these things are
inconsequential or even necessary
sacrifices for the rise of the greater
good of socialism or communism.
And I personally find that morally
reprehensible and I can't understand
where that,
where that comes in,
how you can stand there and be so
opposed to this genocide.
What say that this genocide is somehow
just,
oh,
it's not a problem.
And why do you think that?
How do you think that disconnect
happens?
How do you think people can convince
themselves of that and why do you think
that happens?
It's a great,
it's a great question.
Um,
you know,
I have,
my house is covered with,
with art from the Soviet era,
and I have a road of reasons for that.
Part of it is to remind me of what
happened.
Part of it is to watch the struggle
between the art and the propaganda on
the canvasses sort of in real time.
You know,
I'm very interested in that,
but I would never decorate my house with
Nazi Regalia,
you know,
and you think,
well,
why is that exactly?
It's not like,
I don't know that that what happened in
the communist regimes was utterly
reprehensible.
Why is it,
and perhaps it's not acceptable to have,
you know,
socialist realist paintings in your
house,
but it's certainly more acceptable or it
seems that way than to have paintings
from the Nazi era,
let's say.
So then you think,
well,
why is that exactly?
And I think,
you know,
back in 1918 at the dawn of the Russian
revolution,
when Europe was inflamed and in ruins
and the monarchical societies were
collapsing and the industrial revolution
was in full force and there were
terrible,
there was terrible poverty and terrible
inequality.
The dream of Universal Brotherhood was a
compelling dream,
the dream of egalitarianism and,
and,
and maybe,
maybe who knows how much of it was
motivated by genuine benevolence.
Some,
at least it's very difficult to see that
the Nazi,
the Nazi phenomenon was ever generated
by any genuine benevolence.
That's very difficult to,
to make a case for.
Um,
so maybe you can forgive the,
the socialists,
the communists utopians a hundred years
ago because they didn't know what they
were getting in for.
People had warned them.
Dostoyevsky warn the neat,
neat.
You warn them but,
but still,
and then the other thing too is the
problem of inequality.
It's like the problem of inequality is a
real problem and it doesn't go away.
Like it's very difficult when you walk
down bloor street for example,
in Toronto and you see homeless people,
alcoholics and drug addicts who are
struggling and the mentally ill who are
on the street and they're in their
little domain of hell.
It's,
it's really difficult for that to not
tear at your heart strings and say,
well,
isn't the world and unjust place or an
unfair place,
which it is.
And so you can see the never ending
wellsprings of motivation to support the
oppressed.
And I think the fact that the communist,
the communist dogma,
at least had that as part of its
initiating ethos is partly what seems to
make it forgivable.
I also think it's easier
for people to identify why fascism is
wrong.
We can say,
look,
racial superiority,
nope.
Okay.
It's pretty simple,
right?
It's three words.
You can really get it,
but,
but equality of outcome,
it's like that's really wrong.
It's really wrong.
But it's not so obvious why,
right?
It isn't,
you can't just say quality of outcome,
know and have everyone clap because it
isn't as well.
And that's the thing.
It's really difficult to,
it's difficult to isolate the
pathological elements in radical left
wing thought because they're not self
evidently pathological.
Like there's this old cliche,
um,
from each according to his ability to
each according to his need.
It's like,
yeah,
that sounds pretty good.
We have needs.
It's like,
let's have them fulfilled and well,
you have an ability,
well,
like manifested.
It's like,
well,
it doesn't work in practice.
In fact,
it's murderous in practice and it's a
great catastrophe in some sense that
it's murderous in practice.
So I just think it's maybe part of it
is,
it's just a hell of a lot harder to
learn why it's wrong.
That combined with,
you know,
the genuine outpouring of compassion for
the oppressed and,
and which is like who's for poverty,
no one.
Right.
And,
and inequality is a painful reality.
It's painful for everyone.
You know,
even people who are self righteous about
their,
their status,
let's say in,
in the depths of their soul,
the struggling of the fact of the
struggling still rips at them.
And so
it's a more difficult lesson for us to
learn.
So.
Yup.
[inaudible]
do those people lined up at the mics?
I sorry for leaving you hanging.
I'm sure we could go on all night if we
had the time.
Um,
but we must call this to a close.
I would like to
salute you
for your patients and your dedication in
the face of the noise from outside.
Very nicely done.
Well done.
[inaudible]
as you,
uh,
as you no doubt are aware.
Professor Peterson has written an
international best seller.
It's called 12 rules for life.
There are some presale in the hall now
before you go,
let me just say this,
you have participated in what I would
consider to be an important step in the
life of this university and for that we
should thank you.
So thank you for coming and thank you
for your support.
[inaudible]
professor Peterson,
uh,
maybe the most important intellectual a
voice in this country today.
And I would like to thank him very much.
Calming.
[inaudible]
so
good night,
be safe.
I just have,
sorry,
I just have one small thing to say.
Hold on.
I would,
I would very much like to stay and talk
with a bunch of you and I generally do
that,
but I can't do it today because I have
to go back to Toronto and I'm going to
Australia tomorrow,
so I don't,
I can't do that even though I would like
to,
so I have to run off and then I have to
drive back to Toronto.
But despite that,
thank you very much for coming and for
being patient and all of that.
Yup.
Great.
Yay.
Shame on Queens.
No freedom for hate speech.
Essentially.
Really,
really chosen where I'm at with it.
And I've been looking at his voice and
we're looking at the protest points.
I'm not really sure.
Um,
I just think it's interesting that he's
drawing the sort of crowd and that,
you know,
what's happening here is happening.
I think that really says something about
participation at Queens.
We're here to protest,
uh,
Jordan Peterson,
dean given,
given a platform at Cuny University,
um,
Jordan Peterson,
aside from not knowing what he's talking
about,
these things,
a la pierce intention type featured by
everything grow.
It's not a discussion about which topics
do you like on pizza.
It's a discussion about which people
should be considered,
which you lose your respect and that's
not a debate,
but you happen anywhere.
I love that they are here.
How did this course,
because Lillian,
they don't agree with what he has to say
so they're showing it.
But uh,
I have seen a lot of people call to
cancel.
They are showing the Daniel Walsh should
be ashamed of himself for allowing this
to happen.
And that I just think is wrong.
Oh,
I don't know if it seems like we have a
lot of very angry people here because
someone's expressing an idea different
than their own and here at a university,
I kind of thought that was the point.
Thank you.
Would you like one more Pepsi Cola?
I'm good.
Same those words.
It takes bravery to say of that
acceptable guys.
Yeah.
Like really?
They broke the fucking window.
I'll run in there.
Jesus Christ.
Crazy,
crazy.